marquee calendars Keano fans because to
of Keanu Reaves most anticipated new
projects are currently slated to hit
theaters on the very same day
John wig chapter four and the fourth
Matrix film will both debut on May 21st
2021 create singer possible conundrum
for moviegoers it's certainly an
interesting choice for Warner Brothers
to settle on that specific date for the
matrix for when Summit Entertainment and
Lionsgate already claimed it for John
wig chapter 4 unless audiences want to
catch both on the same day they'll have
to choose one flick to see before the
other whether the studios are trying to
encourage a double feature or see which
property is more popular May 21st 2021
will certainly be a big day of the
movies for Keanu fans since it was
announced in august 20 1944 the fourth
Matrix film which marks a newest
addition to the Virchow skis cannon
since the original trilogy concluded in
2003 with Matrix Revolutions
so far the matrix 4 already has a
star-studded cast found by lana
wachowski and fronted by Reeves as neo
and his matrix co-star Carrie Ann
masters Trinity the cast will also
include Neil Patrick Harris Jada Pinkett
Smith minehunters Jonathan Groff and the
get-down standouts Yaya Abdul Matti in
the second as for John wick the
franchise kicked off in 2014 with former
matrix 2 man Chad's to house Keiko
directing the film thanks to
mind-bending action and a standout
performance from Reeves as an expert
assassin pulled out of retirement
following the death of his dog the first
John wick film was an immediate hit it
spawned two sequels John wick chapter 2
and John wick chapter 3 Parabellum all
three films succeeded at the box office
and the franchise as a whole has
completely changed the action genre
Reeves career Renaissance has been a
long time coming after roles and varied
projects like Bill & Ted's Excellent
Adventure and an adaptation of Bram
Stoker's Dracula
Keano dipped a toe into full-fledged
action films with speed in 1994 before
long there were Chelsea Keys came
calling with the matrix and Reeves Korea
changed overnight thanks to his role as
neo throughout the original trilogy
Reeves cemented himself as a bona fide
star but he had a few rocky years have
followed his matrix success in the myths
of matrix mania and shortly thereafter
Reeves made a string of poorly received
films like sweet November
47 Ronin and the watcher though he
appeared and critically-acclaimed
projects like Richard Linklater's A
Scanner Darkly nothing was quite as
successful as a matrix franchise during
his downtime Reeves stepped behind the
camera making his directorial debut with
the underrated action flick the man of
Tai Chi in 2013 luckily Reeves found
himself reconnecting to the world of the
matrix when he were United with Chad's
to hell ski years later for the John
wick series the franchise restored
Reeves to its full action glory Reeves
insisted on doing most of his own stunt
work for the first film which received
glowing reviews from critics and fans
people keep asking you back and I
haven't really had no yeah I'm taken on
back thanks in large part to John wick
Reaves us firmly back on Hollywood's
a-list and he remains as charming as
ever a truly beloved celebrity for
decades he's even found time to laugh at
himself and between his stone-faced role
as John wick in 2019 Reeves lamb poojas
own image and Netflix's always be my
maybe playing an over-the-top version of
himself and the charming romantic comedy
there's no denying that Reeves has once
again back at the top of his game and a
seemingly better than he's ever been
before
it remains to be seen whether either
summit and Lionsgate or one of brothers
will stand down and chase the release
date for either John wick or the matrix
for of the upcoming films but it's
having both movies debut on May 21st of
that year might be a perfect opportunity
to celebrate all things Reeves check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you